when i was a kid
i was like many of you in this room very
much fascinated by star wars
and what fascinated me the most is this
notion of the force
this energy that connects all people and
all objects and
allows you to feel people that you can't
even see
and i remember many nights i would be
sitting at home just like
concentrating and focusing trying to
feel the force
and i didn't feel anything don't worry
and later in life i became a scientist i
joined the mit faculty
and started working on wireless signals
these are things like wi-fi or cellular
systems and i did a lot of work in that
domain
but then again this force thing
came kept nagging me and at some point i
just like wait a minute
these wireless signals they were like
the force
so if you think about that wireless
signal they travel through space
they go through obstacles and walls and
occlusions
and some of them they reflect off our
bodies because our bodies are full of
water
and some of these minute reflections
they come back
and if just if i had a device
that can just sense these minute
reflections
then i would be able to feel people that
i cannot see
so i started working with my students on
building such a device and i want to
show you some of our earlier results
so here you see my students standing and
here's our device
and we are going to put the device in
the other office
behind the wall and we are going to
monitor him as he moves
the thread dot is tracking him using
wireless signals
and as you can see the red dot is
tracking his movements very accurately
just purely based on how his body
interacts with the surrounding wireless
signals
pretty accurate isn't it
he has no wearables nothing
now you might be wondering how is it
possible that we can
sense people and track them without any
wearable tools
and the easiest analogy to think about
is radar i'm sure many of you have seen
this picture you transmit a wireless
signal to the sky
it reflects off some airplane comes back
to you and you start detecting these
airplanes
but if it were just radar then we would
have this 50 years ago
so it's not just radar there are two key
differences
so the first difference of course you
can't like radar just
blast wireless power at somebody you're
gonna fry them like if they were in a
microwave
don't do that so it means that you have
to be able to deal with
very weak signals and that means that
your device has to be very sensitive
the second difference is like unlike the
sky where
it's empty if you are lucky there is one
airplane that you can catch there
like look at the room and look how many
objects and people there are
so in indoor environment the signal not
only reflects of the person it reflects
of the person
of the floor the ceiling of
other people around and you get very
complex reflection with the same signal
reflects of me
then a few and then of the ceiling then
off the floor
and you have to make a sense of that
mess
but we were lucky we are we were coming
at the right time
so two things helped us the first thing
is uh
radio technologies have evolved a lot
and over the last
decade radio technology became much more
powerful so we were
able to build very sensitive radios that
can sense
weak and minute rf signals
the second thing machine learning so we
keep hearing about machine learning and
there was
a revolution of machine learning
recently in deep learning
and that allowed us to build machine
learning models
that can understand wireless signals and
interpret them
so they would know what happened in the
environment
so if you think of it the radio is like
the ear of our device and the machine
learning is like the brain
and together they have very powerful
device
so what else can we sense about people
using wireless signals sleep
sleep actually is something very dear to
my heart because my sleep is a disaster
and the worst thing is when you start
working on
some physiological signal and you
discover that yours
sucks but
so you can see why we can capture sleep
because the person walks and the device
sees him as he walks to bed when he
stops
tossing around in bed when he steps out
of bed
and that measure of sleep is what people
call ectography
is based on motion but it turned out
that we can actually get sleep at much
more important level
we can understand the change in the
brain waves
that occur during sleep
so many of you probably know that as we
go to sleep our brain waves change
and we enter different stages awake
light sleep deep sleep and ram
or rapid eye movement these tensions are
of course
related to sleep disorders but they are
also related to
various diseases so for example
disturbances in realm
are associated with depression
disturbances in deep sleep
are associated with alzheimer's
so if you want to get sleep staging
today you will send the person to the
hospital they put all of these electors
on their head
and they ask them to sleep like that
it's not really a happy experience
so what if i tell you that i can do the
same thing but without
any of these electrodes on the person's
body
so here is our device transmit very low
power wireless signal
analyzes the reflection using ai and
spits out the sleep stages
throughout the night so it would know
for example when this person is dreaming
not just that we can even get your
breathing
while you are sitting like that and
without touching you so
he's sitting and reading and this is his
inhales
exhales and we ask him to hold his
breath and you see the signal staying at
a steady level
because he exhaled he did not inhale
and i want to zoom in on the signal and
this is the same signal as before
these are the inhales these are the
exhales
and you see these blips on the signal
these are not noise
there are his heartbeats and you can see
them beat by b
so i want to stop here for a moment and
show you a live demo
zach is going to help me with the demo
and what we're going to do we're going
to use the device to monitor exact
breathing so this white box that you see
here
is the device and zac is turning it on
and let's see whether he breathes well
so
uh we're gonna do exactly what we did in
the video with the other guy so we're
gonna
the wireless signal is going through
it's touching zach's body and is
reflecting back to the device
and we want to monitor his breathing his
inhale exhale motion
so we see the inhales exhale so see
these ups and downs exactly breathing
inhaling exhaling
so he can breathe so
zach can you hold your breath please
okay so now he's holding his breast so
he sees the signal stays at steady level
and these are his heart beats
beat b b b
b okay zach you can breathe breathe
again
we don't want accidents here okay thank
you
so as you can see we have this device
that can monitor so many physiological
signals for you
and what is really interesting about
this device that it does all this
without any wearables without asking the
person to change his behavior
or to wear anything or charge anything
special
and that got doctors very excited
because doctors they always want to know
more information about their patients
particularly at home
and this is particularly true in chronic
diseases so chronic diseases like
uh pulmonary diseases like copd or heart
failure or
alzheimer and uh even depression all of
these chronic diseases are very
important in fact
i mean perhaps you know two stories of
the cost of health care in the u.s is
due to chronic diseases
but what is really interesting about
chronic diseases is that when a person
for example has a problem and that leads
to the heart to the hospital and the
emergency room
this problem doesn't happen overnight
actually things happen gradually
so if we can master chronic disease
patients in their home
we can detect changes in their breathing
heartbeat mobility sleep
and we can detect emergencies before
they occur
and have the doctor intervene earlier so
that we can avoid hospitalization
and indeed today we are working with
multiple hospi
doctors in different disease categories
so i'm really excited because
we have deployed the device with many
patients we have deployed the device
with patients that have
copd which is a pulmonary disease
patients that have
alzheimer's patients that have
depression and anxiety and people that
have parkinson's
and we are working with the doctors on
improving their life understanding the
disease better
so when i started i told you that
i'm really fascinated with star wars and
the force in star wars
and indeed and i'm still very much
fascinated
even now as a grown up with star wars
waiting for the next movie
but i'm really very fascinated now
and excited about this new force of
wireless signals
and the potential of changing healthcare
with this new force
one of the patients with whom we
deployed is actually my aunt she has
heart failure and uh i'm sure
many of you guys in the audience have
parents grandparents
loved ones who have chronic diseases so
i want you to imagine with me a future
where in every home that has a chronic
disease patient there is a device like
this device sitting in the background
and just monitoring passively sleep
breathing the health
of this chronic disease patient and
before an emergency occurs
it will detect the degradation in the
physiological signal and alert the
doctor
so that we can avoid hospitalization
this can change health care as we know
it today
improve how we understand chronic
diseases and also save many lives
thank you
dina thank you so much thank you to zach
so glad you're breathing um so dina um
this is amazing the positive
applications are incredible
um what is the framework though around
like the ethical framework around this
what are you doing to prevent this
technology from being used for other
perhaps less positive types of
applications
yeah this is very important question of
course like what about misuse or
what is about the i guess concerned
about the dark side of the fourth
right right
so we we actually have a technology that
um prevent people for trying to use this
device to monitor somebody without their
concern
so because the device understands space
it will ask you to
prove by doing a certain movement that
you have access to the space and you are
the person
who you are asking the device to monitor
so technology technology wise
we have technology that we integrate to
prevent misuse
but also i think there is a role for
policy like everything else
and hopefully we with the two of them we
can control any misuse
amazing thank you so much thank you
[Applause]
thanks